Je m'appelle Delphine bridez,
j'ai 32 ans
et je travaille à L'Hôpital de la croix-roues à Lyon
depuis deux-mille-neuf,
d'abord dans les cuisines, puis en tant qu'infirmière.
J'ai toujours été révoltée par cette
société profondément injuste
où 1 minorité
exploite l'humanité et ça capte toutes les richesses.
Travailler à L'Hôpital
n'a fait que renforcer cette colère.
D'une part, l'accès au soin est de plus en plus
difficile pour les classes populaires
et de l'autre, les conditions de travail se durcissent
avec des journées de
travail qui s'intensifient et se rallonge.
Les gouvernements successifs
ont fait de L'Hôpital
1 usine où il faut réduire les coups
à chaque étage, dans chaque service,
il faut limiter les soins
et faire partir les patients de plus en plus vite.
Cette logique comptable est désastreuse.
C'est 1 politique criminelle
que les directions des hôpitaux tentent de justifier
par la nécessité de rembourser les dettes
contractées auprès des banques.
Mais dans 1 société
organisée pour
transformer
toutes les richesses créées par les travailleurs
en profit pour les capitalistes,
comment imaginer 1 avenir meilleur pour L'Hôpital
sans renverser leur pouvoir ?
Les progrès scientifiques
devraient déjà bénéficier à chacun,
mais pour qu'ils profitent à tous et partout,
il faudra renverser la dictature de la finance